who knew the magical world of harry
potter could be so emotional it didn't
quite feel real and it was a bit it was
a bit traumatic these are the scenes
that left our favorite actors in tears
number one losing sirius black in the
order of the phoenix was one of the most
emotionally charged scenes in the entire
harry potter series daniel radcliffe's
screams of pain were actually cut from
the movie because they were so agonizing
radcliffe had recently lost a
grandfather so he was channeling that
emotion in his performance and it shows
both emma watson and helen and bottom
carter actually started crying because
they were so affected by the rawness of
the performance that's one seriously
powerful performance
number two hermione being tortured by
bellatrix and the deathly hallows part 1
is an extremely disturbing scene turns
out it was even more disturbing on set
emma watson actually researched what it
was like to be tortured beforehand to
properly portray the harrowing
experience the scene itself was
improvised by watson and carter as the
two performed the scene for minutes on
end uninterrupted director david yates
gave the two of them room to build the
intensity of the moment and it most
definitely got intense the screams were
quite horrible to listen to
she was kind of exploring and exercising
demons really and serving the scene
doing that
number three working with the great
jason isaacs is a pleasure right in fact
working with jason was not always a
treat in a deleted scene from the
chamber of secrets jason isaacs hits tom
felton's hand with his cobra cane as he
tries to grab something in the store
however isaacs didn't realize that the
teeth on the cobra were sharp and they
cut poor tom's little hand naturally
this made tom well up with tears as he
tried to brave his way through the pain
turns out this was the first thing
isaac's filmed for the series what a way
to start tom i'm so sorry i didn't
realize how sharp they were and how
heavy it was and he went no no it's all
right it's good for the scene
number four perhaps the most emotional
scene of the entire series was harry ron
and hermione jumping through this portal
in the deathly hallows part one the
reason is it was the last thing ever
shot for the harry potter series
it was the end of an era for the golden
trio daniel emma and rupert all got
teary-eyed after cut was called as the
emotions came flooding in after spending
a whopping 10 years on the movie we
understand why this was such a big
moment this is such an ironic way too i
know it's a very strange lesson
number five ivana lynch joined the harry
potter cast in the order of the phoenix
as luna lovegood this was also the first
movie to feature the room of requirement
where lynch filmed a lot of her scenes
that's why it was very fitting when her
last day of filming was in the room of
requirement making it a full circle
moment for lynch that produced a few
tears i felt like i'd started on the
room of requirement scene and that was
like a learning curve and you learn
magic and then we left and we go out
into the battle and i felt it was so
symbolic
number six tom felton couldn't help but
get emotional when filming the epilogue
scene for the deathly hallows part 2.
knowing it was the last scene of a
character he'd played for the past 10
years was very touching on top of that
he got to share the moment with his
real-life girlfriend jade olivia who
played his wife but the most emotional
part of filming the scene for felton was
actually seeing harry all grown up with
his wife and kids i really thought
daniel did a marvelous job of being
older i got a bit emotional about that
number seven bellatrix may have been a
despised character but helen and bonham
carter got emotional when saying goodbye
to her after playing the character for
five years we can't blame her no i'm
genuinely really sad i've got very
attached to bellatrix she's been a
friend to me
number eight bonnie wright was another
cast member that got emotional while
filming the epilogue scene seeing her
character ginny all grown up married and
with kids struck an emotional cord how
can you not get emotional wrapping up
the story of a character you've been
with for so long so the psychological
journey that obviously we had to take
was very interesting
number nine nobody can escape the
emotions of filming the epilogue scene
knowing it was going to be the last
scene of the entire series made everyone
emotional including the crew and there
were tears shed all around it actually
became so emotional that they had to
film the entire scene twice because
emotions kept getting in the way of
production yeah it's a nice scene it was
it was it's a nice way to end i think
number 10 oliver phelps had to get into
a dark and emotional headspace before
filming the heartbreaking scene of his
character george reacting to his twin
brother fred passing away he was given
the advice to relate the moment to
something that happened in his personal
life and to stay in that headspace even
when not on camera it was a very
emotional charged scene really to to get
people into that mindset you know that
advice paid off as the emotion flowed in
the scene
these scenes were emotional for us fans
to watch so we can't even imagine how
raw emotions were on set these actors
truly gave it their all and the results
speak for themselves